c'est vrai que cette crise elle a été
principalement occidental puisque en
afrique vous l'avez dit la crise est
passée relativement inaperçue ont
peut-être pas en méditerranée mais en
afrique subsaharienne en asie finalement
la crise a été contenue endiguer d'une
manière tout à fait impressionnante dans
des pays qui sont les plus peuplées du
monde et l'asie c'est plus de la moitié
de la population mondiale
or à l'échelle de de l'humanité cette
crise sanitaire mise en scène par
l'occident et finalement dans lequel
l'occident c'est d'une certaine manière
en ferrer ont il est un peu tôt pour
savoir à quel point il ya une forme de
folie collective qui s'est saisi de des
pouvoirs et des peuples occidentaux mais
c'est une crise sanitaire mineurs à
laquelle on a eu fort à faire à
l'échelle de l'humanité vous avez une
humanité avec 7 à 8 milliards
d'habitants
pour l'instant on en est à moins de deux
millions de morts c'est à dire que dans
ces morts sont intervenus dans des pays
âgées dans des pays dans des nations
vieille ce sont essentiellement des
personnes très âgées est très malade qui
sont mortes leur fin de vie a été un peu
abrégé donc si vous voulez par rapport
aux conséquences qui vont être entraînés
sur le reste du monde notamment sur les
nations jeunes ou sur les pays en
développement qui vont subir les affres
et les conséquences de notre arrêt de
notre coup d'arrêt général il y aura
beaucoup de questions à se poser
et c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour faire
un bilan donc pour l'instant on peut
faire le bilan de ce qu'on a vécu à
notre échelle mais à l'échelle
planétaire
c'est clairement une crise de l'occident
c'est peut-être même alors c'est encore
l'histoire le dira mais c'est peut-être
effectivement un tournant notamment par
rapport à notre par rapport à l'asie qui
à tous points de vue s'est montrée je
dirais plus raisonnable et qu'on ne me
dise pas que c'est une affaire de
dictature parce que le japon la corée du
sud taïwan se sont montrés remarquables
y compris des pays très pauvres comme le
vietnam
donc il ya quelque chose dans la
déraison occidentale sur quoi mon avis
faut méditer
[Musique]